spread of the disease what we need to
understand that Russia due to its
geographical position cannot isolate
fully from the rest of the world when
our borders would have countries
severely damaged by the coronavirus we
cannot block the spread of the disease
due to objective reasons but we already
do a lot we work professionally in an
organized manner we work proactively to
deal with the problem and now priorities
are here is the health of our people
we've deployed the highly efficient
system for preventive treatment and
diagnosis we apply everything we have an
I dress you nurses doctors healthcare
professionals working at hospitals
emergency units and scientists as well
you are on the frontline today and I
would like to thank every one of you for
your committed and dedicated work and I
urge everyone to follow strictly the
suggested regulations and ways of
protecting yourself a lot depends on
them especially so it is true for the
high-risk groups the elderly population
and people with chronic diseases for
them and for every other citizen it is
of primary concern today to lower the
risks as much as possible of course we
cannot but make the question of the
amendments vote we have established that
it will take place on the 22nd of April
you know how serious I am about this
vote and I will of course will ask you
to come and cast your votes
express your opinion on this critical
issue for our country for our society
however a
said before our absolute priority is the
health of our people their safety that
is why I believe that we need to
postpone the vote we will assess the
situation in the regions of Russia and
based on professional expertise of our
doctors and scientists we will make the
decision when to have that vote on the
amendments to the Constitution right now
it is important to prevent fast spread
of the disease
that is why I'm announcing the next week
as the week that will not see anyone
working and everyone will have their
salaries as do so up to April the 5th
no-one will be working of course all the
critical services including medical
institutions pharmacies stores banking
institutions transportation institutions
as well as governor and musical
authorities will continue working again
that will be a one week free of work
that is what we are doing to stop the
disease from spreading
I call upon everyone in Russia let's not
work hoping fingers crossed that the
situation will resolve itself
that's not thing that it will never go
as far as you know it can affect you it
can affect everyone we see what is
happening in the world in Europe that
can be our future if we do not act we
need to follow every recommendation out
there we need to care about ourselves
about our relatives and families let's
be disciplined let's be responsible
believe me the safest way is to stay at
home a separate note I would like to
dwell on the car
social economic situation we need to
apply more efforts to ensure social
guarantees for the people so that people
will not lose their income will not lose
their jobs we need to support small and
medium-sized companies because millions
of people are employed in that sector in
that context I'm announcing a number of
measures to take place first all social
benefits for people that are expected to
be given in the next six months will be
prolonged automatically you will not
need to present any additional documents
you will not need to attend any
institutions and let me give you an
example if you are entitled to discounts
on utilities you will not need to
confirm your current income to get that
discount also the benefit payments to
the veterans of war and labor seventy
five thousand and fifty five thousand
roubles so are to be delivered before
the holidays which are due in May we
will also support families with children
in the next three months
starting with April we will be paying to
every family were entitled to maternity
capital additional five thousand rubles
per month for every child younger than
three years three years included that
kind of support will be important for
the families whose children are not
going to kita Gardens today or nurseries
for families where parents are currently
a medical leave or on vacation to care
for their children as for additional
benefits for the children between three
and seven I instructed the government to
accelerate all the necessary work to
make that happen so that the people
would not get these payments in jus by
but in June already in June these
payments will be given to the families I
also call upon the
governance to act faster so that the
information will be circulated in a
expedient manner thirdly we need to
support those who are on medical leave
or who has lost their jobs medical
leaves have been calculated in regard to
the salary and work experience that is
why some people do not get a lot of
money when a medical leave this is
unfair my suggestion is as follows to
install and norm a quota for these
salaries to be paid for those for
medical leave there should not be less
than one minimum wage that will be in
force and will last until the end of the
year Russia's economy as well as
economies of other countries are
experiencing a lot of negative pressure
because of the epidemic and as I said we
need to support those who might be
affected who might lose their jobs today
except for some categories of people the
maximum unemployment benefits are capped
at eight thousand rubles per month I say
we increase that to the minimum wage
twelve thousand rubles twelve thousand
and one hundred and thirty rubles per
month fourthly loans and credits is
another zone of risk of course income is
shrinking and it's hard to pay your debt
sometimes is impossible to pay your
debts that is why we need to introduce
zero loan policy if a person experiences
a difficult situation his or her income
has decreased by more than 30 percent
that person should be entitled to
opposed in credit payments so that the
loan would be prolonged without any
punishment and
additional interests and I call upon
banks to work harder to ensure that
small companies entrepreneurs and
individuals can rely on these guarantees
when people have no income they should
not feel that they are in a deadlock
they should not be taken hostage to
loans I call upon the government and the
Parliament to speed up their work on
introducing these changes to the
legislation small and medium-sized
companies micro companies especially if
they work in the field of services are
today contracted by a number of
difficulties orders are shrinking their
incomes their revenues are going down we
need to reach out to these companies so
that they will continue working
sustainably and will not have to fire
anyone it is our primary task and I call
upon every employer in the country we
need to ensure stability on the labor
market
there should be no increase in
unemployment the government is ready to
help businesses to make that happen
those sectors though industries which
are affected the most by this
troublesome epidemic we will apply the
following measures small and
medium-sized companies will be giving an
opportunity to pay their taxes later
including vit they'll pay the after six
months as for micro companies it's C for
them tree and also they will not need to
pay insurance fees for the same amount
of time as for loans small and
medium-sized companies and micro
companies for fighting themselves
indepedent will be able to pay their
loans further on in time after a six
month period I call upon the government
and the central bank to adopt additional
measures to ensure that
crediting and loan issues is continuing
on a sustainable basis that can be done
through subsidies and governmental
guarantees companies and factories which
are now in a difficult situation should
be protected from bankruptcy that is why
for a period of six tons we introducing
a moratorium on bankruptcy applications
as well as measures related to
collecting the depths from such
companies that is going to help those
who are most affected also the
government is instructed to monitor the
situation 24/7 and when needed these
measures can be expanded and the number
of the category of companies involved
can also be changed and expanded we need
to do our best to support people's
income especially those people working
at small medium sized companies these
companies need to have additional
resources to be resilient and for that
we need to lower the insurance fees for
them down to 15% that will be applied to
salaries which are higher than the
minimum wage level if the seller is at
the level of the minimally shallower
than that then it will be the same 30
percent and again it's not for a couple
of months it's not an anti-crisis
measure that's a long-term plan this way
we'll be creating additional stimulus to
the companies to increase salaries of
their employees so much for insurance
premiums now another measure all
dividends and all inter is going to
offshore US and abroad of Russia should
be
subjected to fair taxes and this is why
today many of the schemes
existing to optimize money flows facing
the tax of 2 percent only while people
have to pay 13% of income tax that is a
huge disparity this is unfair that is
why those who would like to take the
money their dividends outside of Russia
to put on foreign accounts will be
introducing a new tax of 15 percent that
will require of course certain
amendments to the double taxation
agreements that we have with some
countries and the government is to work
this out if our foreign partners refuse
to accept these terms then Russia will
allow these agreements unilaterally and
will start with those countries who see
the majority of resources taking out
from Russia because that is a blow to
our economy secondly in many countries
of the world if we take people and the
money the investments in stocks and
shares they are paying taxes for them we
don't have such a tax and that is why I
suggest that the people who investments
are bigger than 1 million rubles should
be paying a tax on the money they get
from it at the level of 13% not the
deposit not the investment but the money
they get from it their interests now I'd
like to stress that this is going to be
applied only to 1% of bank clients while
all the other terms and conditions will
remain at their current level they are
one of the most profitable today if we
compare them to any other country in the
world these measures are hard but we
need to do that all the additional
revenues that the budget gets from these
two measures will be directed at
financing families with children
families who lost their jobs of those
who are on medical leave citizens of
Russia all the measures which have been
taken and that will be taken in the
future will work they will be effective
if we work together if we understand all
the complexity of the situation if the
government the people will work
shoulder-to-shoulder if we do our best
if we do everything within our power
then we will do it we need to be
responsible for ourselves for our
families of those who need our help our
support largely that is the Solidarity
that we need and this society is defined
by that solidarity by that readiness to
come to others help that is how we
respond to these challenges thank you
for your attention